might bright and cheerful it's some of
the most familiar of all early 18th
century music it's been featured in
uncounted films and television
commercials but what is it and why does
it sound that way this is the opening of
spring from the four seasons by Italian
composer Antonio Vivaldi the four
seasons are famous in part because
they're a delight to the ear however
even more notable is the fact that they
have stories to tell at the time of
their publication in Amsterdam in 1725
they were accompanied by poems
describing exactly what feature of that
season Vivaldi intended to capture in
musical terms in providing specific plot
content for instrumental music Vivaldi
was generations ahead of his time if one
were to read the poems simultaneously to
hearing the music one would find the
poetic scenes synchronizing nicely with
the musical imagery we are told that the
birds welcomed spring with happy song
and here they are doing exactly that
soon however a thunderstorm breaks out
not only is their musical thunder and
lightning there are also more birds wet
frightened have done happy
in summer the Turtledove sings her name
talked Adela in Italian
before a hailstorm flattens the fields
autumn brings eager hunters dashing out
in pursuit of their prey the winter
concerto begins with teeth chattering in
the cold before one takes refuge by a
crackling fire then it's back out into
the storm world will be slips and falls
on the ice in these first weeks of
winter the old year is coming to a close
and so does Vivaldi's musical
exploration of the seasons not until the
early 19th century would such expressive
instrumental prog music as it was known
become popular by then larger more
varied ensembles were the rule with
woodwinds brass and percussion to help
tell the tale but Vivaldi pulled it off
with just one violin strings and a
harpsichord unlike his contemporary Bach
the Volta wasn't much interested in
complicated fugues
he preferred to offer readily accessible
entertainment to his listeners with
melodies that popped back up later in a
piece to remind us of where we've been
so the first movement of the spring
concerto begins with a theme for spring
and it ends with it to slightly varied
from when it was last heard it was an
inspired way to attract listeners and
Vivaldi
considered one of the most electrifying
violinists of the early 18th century
understood the value of attracting
audiences such concerts might feature
himself as the star violinist others
presented the young musicians of the
pietá a Venetian girl school where
Vivaldi was director of music most of
the students were orphans music training
was intended not only as social skills
suitable for young ladies but also as
potential careers for those who might
fail to make good marriages
even in the composer's own time
Vivaldi's music served as diversion for
all not just for the wealthy aristocrats
300 years later it's an approach that
still works and Vivaldi's music still
sounds like trotting horses on the move
you